[Musique]
arrivée triomphale pour rendre riche
duda à son qg de campagne
hier soir il est acclamé par ses
partisans alors au coude à coude avec
son rival pro européen andris duda
soutenues par droit et justice le parti
conservateur au pouvoir revendiquer déjà
sa victoire
je suis content de ma victoire pour le
moment dans les sondages et lors du
premier tour mon score a continué à
augmenter avant les résultats définitifs
je voudrais inviter monsieur rafale
trajkovski pour qu'on se serre la main
et pour que cette poignée de main à
chaque cette campagne andré joly dyke
est alors talonné par le maire de vars
ou du rafale trajkovski qui représente
plateforme civique le principal parti
d'opposition centriste croyez lui
toujours à la victoire
le résultat n'a probablement jamais été
aussi serrée dans l'histoire de la
pologne
nous n'avons jamais autant ressenti le
pouvoir de notre vote
vraiment chaque vote peut être décisif
cela donne à chacun de vous un pouvoir
incroyable et nous ne pouvons pas
gaspiller cette force
nous continuerons à lutter pour
l'égalité pour que la pologne sont
ouvertes
une élection à couteaux tirés qui a
connu une forte mobilisation des
polonais 67 9% sont allés voter un taux
de participation élevé pour départager
deux candidats aux antipodes
les détracteurs dandrès duda l'accusent
de faire reculer les libertés
démocratiques en cause les réformes
judiciaires mis en place par le parti
droit et justice
raphaël trajkovski avait lui promis de
faire marche arrière concernant cette
refonte du système judiciaire
critiquée par bruxelles